[Music]
Hi Well lookie lookie she is the perfect
fit I promise did she even see you she
was about
to what are you doing don't do
this no no no
[Music]
hi oh God
starts this is just so exciting what is
happening well that's a perfectly
understandable question give a num I'm
an if get it imaginary
friend our kids grew up so we need new
ones you could save all of us all of who
and don't don't say
ifs let him say it or I think his head
may actually
explode
[Music]
fine thank you you ready for
this my
tonight there's no telling who's behind
that door
today we have to help them yes we
do I can
[Music]
still not going to ask you again put
some pants on you're freaking everyone
out starting to see why I live Al
alone
ke kind of a kid creates an invisible
[Music]
don't uh don't don't look him in the eye
which one you know damn well which
one thanks for doing this it really
means a whole
[Music]
lot